the layer hyaluropan show
[Music]
sponsored by step finance
your go to d5 portfolio manager on
solana
luna if you're just getting into bitcoin
it's the perfect place to start
[Music]
hey guys and welcome back to another
episode of the lehigh queen show super
excited because today we are talking
about my favorite thing in the whole
wide world we are talking about freedom
we are talking about bitcoin and
everything that's going on in the world
we do have somebody all the way from
australia um he's obviously not in
australia right now um but we're gonna
get into it anyway so like i said he is
really interesting um he's also a
bitcoin og so that's going to be really
fun learning how the spaces change so
joining me today is the co-founder of
step finance george harap
george welcome to the show how are you
hi leia oh it's great to be here i'm i'm
good i'm good
i'm really excited to speak to you um
there's so much to discuss so for those
that don't know um
george is a bit of a bitcoin og he's
been in the space for
um it's 11 years now is that right yeah
i'd stop counting after it gets past 10
or something so
that is so insane and you know you're
george is big on freedom he's got
australian roots so we're gonna get into
all of it um but just to kick things off
really you have been in the space for 11
years um i think you're one of the first
miners and i know that there is an
interesting story behind this so
you got in in 2010 tell me the story
about this
yeah so i it was a different world back
then um you know there was bitcoin was a
website that made me maybe like a couple
hundred computer nerds really cared
about um and uh there wasn't all of this
you know uh podcasts and videos and
documentation and everything like that
so uh it was quite a fringe thing back
then but uh i came across it because of
my interest in like uh
like computer hardware basically it was
like oh you can mine these digital
internet coins and i knew nothing about
finance at the time i didn't come from
it you know from that angle um i was
just sort of a random tech guy at the
time uh working a a crappy job uh
packing boxes uh while doing my my
studies so um so no that was great um
got into it sort of just building
uh a minor in my spare time in my room
it was a heater which made money that's
the best kind of heater um and i used to
buy parts off ebay and i used to just
sort of piece them together and do stuff
like that you know wait how did you have
to stop you because people keep saying
yeah i just built it what do you mean
it's what 2010 you're building a
freaking miner like what
yeah yeah yeah so i mean back then like
it was all sort of you could basically
mine uh bitcoin on a laptop um and then
it sort of progressed into uh
progressively more difficult so it
started with the laptops everyone could
do that then it was like you could have
a graphics card and a computer a little
bit more expensive and then you know
people had all these newfangled sort of
ways to increase the processing power to
uh to try and uh try and get more
bitcoin so um yeah look i was at the
forefront of all of those different
phases so whether it was you know gpus
whether it was asics whether it was fpga
slightly before then um i was in the
first batch and basically what happened
is i couldn't afford like i was a poor
student i couldn't afford like a fancy
minor and back then there wasn't like
all of these companies and stuff doing
it it was literally just a bunch of
random people um so i took out a loan
that i couldn't afford um i just like
maxed out whatever the slider was on my
bank and i was like oh i pay a 20
interest rate yeah whatever who cares
let's just do that and
um and buy a bitcoin miner and then also
back then like you could go and give the
money to some like shady entity overseas
and you don't know if the miners can
actually arrive on your doorstep um like
how is that whole you know thing gonna
work so anyway i did that and uh the
company happened to be in in sort of
rural middle of nowhere america so i
thought well i probably should go and
see where this mine is being
manufactured so i got on a plane i went
to kansas city missouri and uh and then
i saw uh people might remember butterfly
labs back then i went and visited them
and blah blah but uh yeah so i was sort
of one of the first asic batches and
they were the people that um were the
first ones to do it um so so yeah i sort
of decided to get on a plane and like
the dude met me at the airport and uh he
was like oh yeah we're not ready to go
you know see the see the miners yet um
but do you want to go up in my plane
and i was like i was like all right um
sure yeah early 20s some guy is going to
take you around in a plane sounds pretty
good so we did that and it was a fun
experience and yeah i got to see the
operation looks pretty much legit
and yeah sort of got started from there
but you know fast forward a few years um
little guys couldn't really compete
anymore you know that's where you had
the industrial people coming in like a
big factory full of it uh you know
millions of dollars invested in these
machines so hey that was time for me to
exit and get out of there probably about
uh 2014 something like that
what a story i mean
did you get to mine a lot of bitcoin
yeah i so i mined a little bit i lost a
lot of bitcoin um i eventually did pay
back my 20 interest rate loan um okay
and that was like after six months of
delay of delivery of these things and
blah blah so like i think i went through
a crash course and you know one thing
when you're young you don't value money
um so like back then uh i was i was
making decent money but then you know on
the forums there'd all be these these
different investment schemes that people
get into i would lose money on those
right um the whole mindset of oh you
just gotta huddle and that's all you
have to do that didn't exist it was kind
of like people were always looking for
some sort of uh
yield or something like that or
borrowing or you know some sort of thing
there was always something
yeah that's crazy because i know
everybody who got in at the beginning um
always um
says you know they didn't have that same
mentality and i think that's why
nowadays the mentality is so strong i
think that's why bitcoin maximalism is
so strong to protect because a lot of
people obviously lost a lot of money um
so really just to protect people but
you are traveling around the world
you're a digital nomad is that what you
would call yourself
yeah i guess you could say that yeah
so let's understand why because the
reason i ask why
because i know that it could sound fun
to be a digital nomad but i i've tried
it to some extent
and i find it really difficult you know
working
maintaining a healthy lifestyle like i
find it difficult being on the go so
like
why are you doing it why didn't you just
settle in one place
yeah like people often think oh you're
jets sitting around and you just go and
like stay in awesome hotels and you hang
out and wouldn't that be fun um i've
been doing it for two years now and it's
i'm kind of coming to the maybe to the
conclusion that having sort of multiple
locations around the world that you
spend more time in is better than sort
of short stints here and there um and i
guess you know i've i've been been doing
it for a while been to like seven
different countries all throughout you
know this pandemic times uh you know
georgia dubai
um
portugal
been here in turkey
um in a couple of other countries here
and there as well uh greece um london uh
uk so uh sort of been around in a bunch
of different places sort of just
optimizing for what is the place which
is going to
like not get up in my business basically
like no they're not going to tell me
what what i have to do when i walk out
the front door
and you've seen like especially uh in
australia and other places where like oh
you can't even like walk three
kilometers from your home and oh who's
measuring the three kilometers why not
2.98 like are you gonna go and like you
know discuss that on an app with a
policeman like that sounds dumb so um so
yeah i don't want to be part of any of
that so i've kind of just been bouncing
around for a while just trying to find a
place with with uh you know a good mix
of everything that i'm that i'm looking
for and and i guess you know what is
that that that these nomads look for i
think one thing that people um
people don't value in the beginning is
community and having like other nomads
other people to talk to when you're in
one place you have your friend group
right and you go and see them every so
often and maybe you know go out for
dinner or whatever it's quite easy
whereas if you're in a strange foreign
country and you don't speak the language
and you know your bank cards probably
get shut down or something like that
because nothing works
or they think that you're somewhere else
or something like that it can be quite
hard so um i think one thing yeah
definitely there's these nomad hubs
around the world which seem to be sort
of coalescing a bunch of different
people uh in different cities so i think
that's probably the way forward is a lot
of people that have the same sort of
like-mindedness all coalesce in the same
place and uh and that's way better than
trying to do it solo yourself
yeah i think um that is so important i
know mexico tulum
has like
both of those places have a good um
digital nomad community but
you so you said that you you started
this two years ago was this directly
because of the pandemic
yeah pretty much um australia i was in
hong kong so uh i lived in hong kong for
six years um and i had a startup there
which i co-founded which was the first
crypto remittance startup um you know
using bitcoin initially to send money
around the world a bunch of different
countries um so our core audience was uh
cash to crypto but the problem was that
when the pandemic came like all of the
physical cash locations they all had to
shut their doors it's basically our
business zero um and in that case it was
like well we don't know how long this
thing's going to last all of our
customers have gone to zero it's time to
wrap up the company and move on to the
to the next thing so yeah i left in
early 2020 and i got on a plane to new
zealand at the time which wasn't as
crazy as this now but um yeah back then
it was uh it was it weathered it a much
better for the first say six months than
the rest of the world the rest of the
world got a little bit crazy but uh nz
was okay but then nz got crazy so
uh
yeah did you
yeah i mean like sorry just say did you
have plans to go back to australia or
even new zealand
um not really i mean right at the moment
right now like as australia has been
banning um their own citizens of coming
back to their country
and i knew that yeah yeah and they've
been doing that for a while unless you
meet all of these different criteria and
also you need permission to leave so
just like a prison colony back in the
day you need the overlords you know
ascent in order to leave so you have to
listen to all of australia yeah yeah so
i think they've recently changed the
rules a little bit but it's still like
if if you haven't uh been vaccinated to
the nth degree of whatever that is um
then uh then you still have to seek
permission you still have to do all this
stuff you have to prove everything in
the borders um if you don't they'll send
you to you know middle of the desert
somewhere to to go and hang out there
for two weeks so
man i don't want any of that so um yeah
like it's it's just so silly so uh yeah
i think there are like other people like
myself where like you have an australian
passport and it says on the front page
um oh you know you shall allow this
person passage uh freedom towards you
know entry into australia at any time
blah blah most countries have this
little spiel at the front um but then it
just doesn't apply you know someone just
clicks their fingers makes a rule oh
yeah sorry no it doesn't apply oh okay
yeah was that in the contract of the
passport or not like you know so um yeah
i i don't really see myself um you know
doing too much there anymore
do you know what i found out yesterday
actually um
our passports are not our property it's
actually the government's property i
didn't know that so you don't own it
yeah so you don't actually own it so
they can just take it from you my
brother actually told me that yesterday
um so that is crazy do you have family
in australia still
i do you know i know i'd love to i'd
love to visit them but uh but i can't
really so it's kind of like how do you
optimize for that like it's
it's kind of like can i get people to
come out but then i've heard of stories
of people having to uh contract lawyers
to write letters to the health ministry
um to get correct
i've heard the same stories exactly yeah
so certainly
i've been speaking to some people at
conferences and they've said they've had
to do that so it is quite a quite a
process to try and actually like just
just get on a plane
i'm so sorry like i um i was spending
some time in america and i was thinking
about my family in england and like i
just didn't know what the future was of
england and like luckily it's okay but
you know at the time i'm just like
it's hard you know um but anyway moving
on moving on from australia you are
literally living off of crypto which is
wild i'd really love to understand how
you do that and then also when you're
traveling are you choosing places which
are specifically crypto friendly
yeah definitely crypto friendly helps um
some of the countries certainly around
sort of the middle east region and uh
eastern europe are generally pretty good
for crypto and and pretty good for like
freedom and that sort of thing um so
like when i was in georgia for a while
uh georgia has a lot of minors as well
uh they have uh pretty easy uh
regulations on anything um and uh you
know anyone can just sort of turn up
before pandemic times they had a visa
which was the tourist visa it's
literally just one year for everyone so
just get a stamp boom one year see you
later georgia yeah for georgia so not
many countries have that right like it's
usually oh it's three months but it's
you know two months within this time
period and different things so
it's also about like trying to optimize
for what what what are the rules in
these different locations as well as as
well as crypto but yeah i think for for
now like you know i've been booking all
of my accommodation with crypto um i've
been paying attention
well there's like intermediary websites
so like what
uh so travala is is a good one
um they have so they actually have the
expedia back end um so everything that's
on there flights or hotels it's pretty
reasonably priced it's not amazing but
hey it's the convenience of being able
to transact um and uh yeah so so you can
book how does that work sorry sorry to
interrupt you but how does it actually
work because i know i know travala
really well i know the founder he's a
friend of mine but i i've never used it
i just haven't because if i'm booking
something in crypto i just use my
crypto.com card which is basically fiat
but you just top it up encrypt it right
um and then you get the three percent
cash back so like how does it how does
it work i don't understand so you can
use like a crypto.com card but the
problem is i don't have a proof of
address because i don't live anywhere so
and i haven't had a proof of address for
literally years so
um i have to find all of these
alternative things um so yeah like with
a with say travala like they uh you find
a listing you find a hotel that you want
to stay at cool um go through the
booking process and then when the
payment comes they'll give you a list of
different uh cryptocurrencies you can
pay and whatever um even stable coins
and stuff like that and you just send it
like address to address yeah yeah
very easy but the problem is like often
as well i've noticed um is all of these
different countries they often have like
their own payment um mechanisms that
only support cards locally so i found
that when i was trying to book stuff
when i was in the uae um georgia has
similar things turkey has similar things
so if you want to uh you know just you
know use the food delivery app or
something you need a card from that
country so even though it says visa or
mastercard on it it doesn't mean
anything and then also there's also like
weird restrictions that you wouldn't
think like say the crypto.com card it
would be classified internally and say
visa system as like a debit card um and
then some payment providers in some
countries don't accept debit cards they
only accept credit cards and credit
cards are tied to banks and banks in
that local jurisdiction so yeah yeah
yeah it's it can become really hard
really quick um to try and sort of weave
it so but luckily some of these
countries are also pretty easy to go and
open like a fiat bank account you can
literally turn up there with a passport
same day they give you a card doesn't
even have your name on it um and then
off you go george is like that yeah yeah
um turkey a little bit like that as well
um other places you were able
you were able to open a bank account in
turkey yeah yeah absolutely yeah
yeah that's amazing it's super easy you
know and certainly in asia when i was
living in hong kong like forget that
trying to do that really easily like you
can spend weeks at hsbc arguing over you
know them needing a piece of paper to
prove that you exist
um so it's really quite fascinating that
look um the fiat system can be uh can be
quite interesting in some of these sort
of emerging countries
that is fascinating because i spent
about three months trying to open up a
business bank account in england
with barclays um i got it in the end woo
you know thank you for letting letting
me give my money to you
but yeah i mean that's just that's just
so insane so that's fascinating about
turkey actually because the president of
el salvador was recently in turkey um
that was rumored to be
about bitcoin um so
what what do you know much about the
sentiment in turkey right now is it
particularly bitcoin crypto friendly
it's super crypto friendly like um for
for us and i think probably most
exchanges and crypto companies out there
um turkey is usually like top three in
terms of audience of users for for
whatever it might be um and that's the
case for us as well but you see it like
bus stops or advertising apps which do
stuff um there's like otc desks like
walking down the street in some places
like you see like all of these different
coins just on the wall and they're like
yeah you can like just do a hundred
thousand dollars if you want there or
you can do like 100 bucks um just walk
in cash boom done um so uh so yeah you
know there's that kind of stuff going on
here which is super cool
why do you think it's so friendly though
well um
i think well here's the thing right and
this is what i've always thought is the
best rules and regulations and no rules
and regulations so in the case of turkey
there aren't really any prescriptive
rules and regulations for things and as
soon as governments and and uh you know
regulators they get in the way they go
and like do a white paper that takes
them six months to do they go and hire a
bunch of people from pwc to go and write
it they come up with like a hundred
different things of crypto regulations
and they go well this is going to bring
all of the people to our country and
everyone's going to love it and it's
going to be great i haven't really seen
any country that's sort of actually done
that and it's it's generated more
interest in that country of people
wanting to go there like i was i was
involved in what is it the isle of
jersey the isle of man um in their
initial uh introductions for crypto
regulation many years ago and they were
trying to be this crypto harbor oh if we
pass all of these rules then that'll
attract people didn't work out um and
you know the reason was it was just too
hard to do anything so i think the moral
of the story is if you just keep it easy
you just let people if they want to
freely exchange with each other you know
some bananas or a coin for a banana or
whatever it might be you just let them
go and do that
now obviously most states are probably
not going to like that they're going to
want to cut along the way so it's kind
of like how do you balance those two
things right some states will go
heavy-handed they'll make a bunch of
rules and regulations which like make
everyone flee like we saw in new york
and a bunch of other places but uh yeah
just keep it open and free that's the
best way
that is literally the only way um it's
funny that you say that i can't what did
i see today oh i saw um
somebody who tried to
a candidate to be um the mayor of new
york actually spoke today about wanting
to um ban bitcoin mining i'm just like
do you think i was like have you guys
not ruined new york enough like what are
you doing
like you are literally destroying your
own place um
but anyway so back to like living off of
crypto so in terms of booking things
you're using travala which is really
cool um but you don't have an address
right so like it's hard to open up a
bank account um so
how do you do that and then also how are
you paying for things like groceries or
paying for a taxi like are you getting
ubers
yeah
it's a good question um yeah i guess
like the proof of address thing that's
an eternal problem um one of the things
is well if you want to get stuff off
amazon when you're living in the uk or
something very easy you press a few
buttons and then it comes to your door
the next day um often i'm using friends
addresses here and there to get the
packages sent
maybe i get something sent to my hotel
if i need to buy something online or
whatever it is um and uh yeah just
storing stuff as well is pretty hard but
often cash comes in handy um certainly
in in sort of eastern europe middle east
uh basically
cash to crypto places so you can go like
a bitcoin atm or something um or you can
go to one of these otc shops um or you
can use you know one of the few cards
which does work on an atm i think i have
um
something like 15 different bank
accounts at the moment but only like
five of them work so the other ones are
just like just don't work because i've
been you know open one up in different
countries right um and just put like a
minimum amount in there but then as soon
as you leave the country like it doesn't
work with a new phone number and yeah
forget it like i remember being on the
phone once with one of the georgian
banks being like uh i'm in the uk i'm
using an icelandic vpn i'm using a phone
number from the united states which is a
voip number by the way and i can't
accept calls on it um and i'm also
telling you that i'm not in georgia
anymore and i want to change my phone
number to something else so forget like
anyone trying to compute all of that
right so you know there is um a bit of
craziness which no bands do have to
navigate um yeah
so um in turkey
i know um that the fiat currency is not
doing very well what's the overall
sentiment right now
yeah i think like there's a bit of doom
and gloom from the outside world of oh
you know it's terrible everyone's
queuing up for food i haven't seen that
um i've been
yeah like i go to the the supermarket
it's got everything there everything's
super cheap um certainly if you're a
local turk and you're earning you know a
fixed income in lira that's bad when the
currency depreciates 80 you know in a
year um you know so is that what it's
done it has depreciated eighty percent
and it's nothing like that yeah i
remember seeing it when it was at like
eight to the dollar and then it went up
to like 18 and then it went back down to
13 i think it's at the moment or 14 so
um yeah crazy times right um but uh yeah
so
i don't see any of the craziness and i
think you know i spoke to someone today
as well you know one of the the local
exchange operators and
he was saying that actually people kind
of see it as a way out and a way out for
a middle class as well because often you
know if you're a you know a doctor or a
lawyer or something like that um you
know there's not really too many ways to
sort of increase your purchasing power
without say investments so a lot of
people i think in these you know
different countries around the world
might be seeing it as an investment
thing which i guess it does conflict
with the initial vision of crypto you
know you've got to start with the
philosophy before really you get into it
um but uh but hey i i do
consider that hey people see their
savings account depreciate by 80 and
they're probably just looking for an
escape valve so yeah
i mean even in lebanon i believe that
the lebanese pound crashed like 90 since
um
it's just it's just insane like i i have
like this prediction that we're seeing
so much um adoption right now but i just
don't think we're gonna see that kind of
adoption from
the i don't even want to say the west
from more developed
countries i just i just don't think
that's where the adoption is going to
come from it's it's kind of like the
same way that crypto for the individual
is that way to kind of
jump you know generational wealth and
build generational wealth and all this
stuff so i think we're going to see the
same thing with countries like el
salvador the rest of latin america
turkey like we'll see in the middle east
um yeah i mean if you've got if you've
got nothing to lose you know these
countries are definitely going to go for
it i think so el salvador is a good
example right they they usd was was the
the local currency previously um and
they don't have any monetary policy over
that there's like 22 different
currencies pegged to the us dollar as
well and most of uh sub-saharan africa
is pegged to the euro in some way with
these different currency consortiums the
euro that is held to back those
currencies is in paris um and the usd
that is
held to back some of these other
different countries around the world
held at the federal reserve
so you know these countries they're kind
of screwed in their national currency
and they can't really price things
correctly um so i think that yeah like
crypto is that escape valve uh it is
something that you know they can get one
step ahead and um yeah like you've got
nothing to lose you know why not uh if
you're being screwed by uh the imf and
the world bank coming into your country
and giving you extortionate loans and
these sorts of things and us dollars
nominated and you're already you know
you know not a productive country that
can pay it back um you might be thinking
of you know taking a bet on something
else and i think that's i think as well
like there will be more countries
perhaps this year uh you know el
salvador obviously you know forging away
um but uh but there are a lot of just
sort of random little island places
around the world which have no real
reserves but it's it's like do you want
to be do you want to create something
valuable for your country and you know
increase the wealth um because crypto is
a good way to do that there's people
like myself which will get on a plane
and go wherever in the world that it's
crypto friendly and they'll just work
there they'll invest there they'll go
and buy you know maybe a house or food
or whatever in your country and that's
good that's not going to happen
otherwise so yeah i think it's
when people realize that um you know
it'll uh it'll do pretty well and i
think portugal is probably doing a good
job of that attracting the crypto people
recently um you know there's a lot of
buzz about uh being nomad there and you
know they're crypto friendly and blah
blah um so yeah maybe we'll see more of
that from from other places yeah i think
it's it's so interesting because it's
not just about um
changing financial systems right like
it's not just about adopting bitcoin
it's about putting the country on the
map particularly in terms of tourism
like el salvador's tourism i don't even
i don't i don't even need to look at
statistics i don't care i'm going to
just say that el salvador's tourism has
probably shot up since
um they've announced you know bitcoin is
legal tender people they should they
should open up i was talking to i think
it was jason williams about this like a
few months ago actually um that they
should open up some kind of like tourist
the thing for the the volcanoes to see
the volcanoes which are powering the
bitcoin network um i've been dying to
get to el salvador you know i want to
spend money there i want to um add value
to the or not that i want to i will end
up adding adding to the economy because
i want to see what's happening um so
absolutely it's so much more than just
changing uh monetary networks um but you
mentioned the philosophy so i really
love to understand your thoughts on the
philosophy behind bitcoin i know a lot
of people say that it is apolitical i
understand why they say that but at the
same time i'm always like it's not that
political
yeah um i think ever since i've been in
in bitcoin like initially it started as
uh something which is against the nation
state and ultimately that's where it
wound up um it it you can say whatever
you want and you can like people come
out and they'll go oh we're gonna make a
fund for it and you know institutional
investors are going to get into it and
countries adopt it but fundamentally
nation states rely on their their local
national currencies and uh and if they
can't print that out of thin air and
create it and debase it and do all these
sorts of things then they can't pay the
people with guns the police officers to
enforce their rules so i think
ultimately crypto hasn't been tested yet
and this has always been the thing
crypto's you know uh bitcoin's either
going to be worth a zero or a million
dollars that's sort of you know my
philosophy on it is that if it really
does solve this political problem and
people see a a world where we transition
you know nation states to perhaps you
know living within their means like by
the way many of them had to for
thousands of years using gold which they
couldn't debase um
or at least you know not as easily um i
think yeah it would be better for the
world but look there's gonna be some
teething problems there and uh people
are gonna fight it and certainly the
vested interests are gonna fight it so
we crypto hasn't been tested um just
just yet and i think a lot of countries
come along with banning and these sorts
of china's try to do it 10 million times
doesn't work um you know we'll sort of
see what happens when some of the
developed sort of western countries try
and and ban it and go after people a bit
more i do think that's the ultimate end
game and anything in between is kind of
like a nice blissful period of of the
the in-between world
but i think that if you take it to the
logical conclusion like bitcoin crypto
it's either going to be 0.5 of gdp 2
percent of gdp 5 20
at what point do you see that reversing
and why why would that ever reverse like
let's say it gets to 20 why would it go
back to 15 or 10 people just decide oh
you know what like um you know a digital
money that's easily accessible on my app
i don't want that i'm going to use a
thing which i have to kyc for and jump
through 10 hoops and then they can take
it from me and and all these sorts of
things so i you do reach i think and
especially like you said in some of i
guess you would say like developing
countries that have nothing to lose um
like i think they are going to really
lead the way um and i'm super excited
for for them leading the way um so yeah
it's gonna be fun
yeah i agree with you i also think that
um because right now el salvador is
obviously getting a lot of um uh uh
getting a lot of rubbish i guess i put
it that way um just simply but
in some ways gambling the country's
money right because bitcoin's obviously
crashed a lot since um since its
all-time high i believe that they did
buy in at around 60k it could be wrong
but i think they did um so i don't know
um you know how
that's going to be for them so they're
getting a lot of rubbish for that and so
i'm excited to get to another point
which i believe would be in about four
years where our you know in the next
cycle um where the new lows
are like two three hundred thousand
dollars for one bitcoin right rather
than like what we're seeing now um and
then that would make a lot of sense when
you're putting the country's reserves um
you're buying it at around
50k
bitcoins at 300 000. that's amazing
that'll be some incredible gain so i'm
excited for them to sort of prove
themselves um
but anyway moving on from bitcoin a
little bit i know that you obviously i
said are the co-founders of step finance
um so
tell me about step because that is
dedicated to solana so you must be
somewhat bullish on solana
yeah absolutely um but i'm also bullish
on d5 as well you know we spoke about
all of these different payment card
problems and uh you know sometimes some
countries might work effectively for
being able to pay for stuff locally
sometimes not um and d5 really is like
the financial system of like bitcoin
itself is is more like a reserve
currency whereas defy is more of all the
other things whether it's loans uh
whether it's um you know swaps or
something like that last year when i was
in nz i was a borrowing against some of
my crypto to uh it was literally paying
me to borrow and then i would go and buy
like a big mac and then my big mac had a
positive roi so you know just crazy
stuff like that that you can do right so
every time you buy a big mac it's uh
it's going to increase in in value
um but you know there's sort of lots of
different interesting things that you
can do in define and again innovation is
not limited you know there's always
someone somewhere that's going to come
out with some random thing that you
never heard of um which is going to do
something pretty good so i think yeah
solana's obviously going down that route
um i guess last year you would say might
be the year of nfts and all these
different things yes there's all sorts
of different other things happening but
i'm most bullish i think on
decentralized finance applications where
i don't need to
struggle with my card being a debit card
and not a credit card and issued in the
wrong country and therefore it doesn't
work even though it's literally a visa
um you know so are there other things
which which we can do other financial
applications which um you know people
can pay for stuff uh which will work the
problem is like merchant processing and
paying for stuff in crypto like that's
been an old problem that's been around
for many years no one's really nailed it
um but i do think d5 with the with the
loans and the borrowing against thing um
that is something new and i think a lot
of these crypto people like maybe they
just want to get a mortgage entirely in
crypto and uh like don't want to
interface with the fiat system at all
and and this is their way to do that um
these different applications so yeah
it's step you know all of these
different applications they come
together in one place that's what we're
all about is like put all of those
different things which might constitute
your portfolio
into one location and uh yeah you know
solana is sort of what we focus on at
the moment that's what's seeing a lot of
this a lot of this growth um and uh
actually what we're seeing is you know
people talk about um you know fees for a
lot of these blockchains and these sorts
of things and yeah i mean look it's been
spoken about for years but it does
impact um you know people that are new
getting into it i'm sure you've probably
come across friends family they have
like maybe 50 bucks or 100 or something
and they want to get into it and you're
like uh you know what can you tell them
to do um and if you have to go on
something like ethereum that costs you
like 200 to do anything i mean forget it
um so yeah i think there is an
opportunity to onboard the masses and
this is just another way of onboarding
more people in decentralizing finance
and through that they'll find out about
bitcoin they'll find out about el
salvador they'll find out about all this
different stuff the problem is like you
just got to create financial
applications which are better than the
existing alternatives and certainly in
many places like you know they don't
have uh access at your finger to invest
in whether it's stock markets or get
loans without permission in like 90
percent of the world so so this is
really the way to achieve that i think
so yeah that that's why i'm bullish on
on solana and what we're doing instead
help me understand because i struggle
with d5 like i get i get the point right
like i i'm with it i get it i support it
my problem is it's just so new and
there's always ragpu after rugpul um and
i never i find it so difficult
understanding how to navigate it so
where do you start you know you're the
digital nomads you're the one living off
of crypto
what protocols are you using getting
great staking rewards apys
help me out here
yeah so i think that firstly it does
help to get an understanding of the
ecosystem like a lot of people might
come into it they're like where do i put
my money what do i do and then they just
go someone told them to go over there so
i'm gonna go over there um but it's just
like uh bitcoin like bitcoin there's
been many exchanges that have been
hacked and lost money over the years i
remember mount gox back in the day um
you know that was a fun time so like
these things have existed before we have
navigated all of these different
problems along the way so it's no
different um you know why would you put
your money at mt gox as opposed to
anywhere else well maybe you know you
didn't trust them um or whatever well
okay that means you need to do research
so same with d5 protocols so lana has a
bunch of them we put a lot of those on
step um so whether it's yield farming i
think that's also one way in for for new
people to not really take too much risk
is let's say you have a stable coin 100
you can get yields of like 20 percent on
that in in d5 and pretty easily um so it
gets scared but it always gets scared i
don't know like the rug pulls and the
hacks like
i'm not good at defy
surprisingly i think you'd be surprised
there's not really if you look at a
percentage of like the actual money
that's in there that it's not really
that much um like i think the total
value indeed now something like 380
billion last time i looked at a chart it
was probably like a month ago um 380
billion is a lot of money um and uh i
think that that the numbers coming out
for different hacks here and there it's
pretty insignificant to to a lot of that
so
i would just say like anyone interested
it's it does do some research um and i
wouldn't like take anyone's word for
what you should do but i would just sort
of direct people to look at different
areas i think yield farming certainly an
easy area you can just have a stable
coin you can earn you know a good yield
in your stable coin you can get used to
it um solana has a bunch of farms like
that we put them on step um so uh so
yeah something along those lines to get
started
and you i just want to go back a second
you've been obviously been traveling
around the world so
in terms of um products
blockchains
protocols cryptocurrencies
what would you say is most needed right
now so i ask like just my train of
thought is okay so bitcoin has this
narrative that it's this store of value
right
um so when you go to turkey and you go
to these places are people
transacting in bitcoin or are they
finding these d5 protocols more useful
in terms of lending and borrowing
mortgages and so on
i think definitely people are on
boarding into like the web 3 stuff um
i'm not seeing people talking about
lightning or anything like that uh in
anywhere that i've been like you saw
that with twitter right i think they
enabled lightning a couple months back
they did it and then everyone forgot
about it because like you know there's
maybe not that much interest in it but
there is interest in a lot of these defy
things so um yeah i think people
you know fees are important to them
speed is important to them um there's a
bunch of different apps that can do
things fast and you can pay for stuff
there has been for like 10 years
but i think yeah some of these new
financial things where people can either
get a yield or get a loan um that kind
of stuff is new and yes like you know
the maxis will say oh there's tons of
different blockchains and you're right
there is tons of different blockchains
um i think it's worth having a look at
these different blockchains and seeing
you know for your own you know education
what they're actually trying to do and
looking into a little bit further so you
know tbl is one metric which people can
do that you know total value lock the
amount of money that people are putting
on there um a lot of people can make a
lot of claims but uh if you you know if
some defy thing has you know 100 billion
dollars in it or something it's probably
worth looking into and there's probably
a bunch of people which are interested
to to use it absolutely so with
everything that we have you mentioned
web three you like for people who are
just tuning in now just to remind you
george has been in the space since 2010
so he's been he's basically a bitcoin og
one of the first miners
um so i want to know how the space has
changed i know we spoke at the beginning
and you sort of said you know we didn't
have these podcasts we didn't have this
kind of infrastructure but tell me more
how has the space changed since 2011
10 sorry
yeah um look i i think
it the the discussion points um some
have changed and some have maybe not uh
i think the discussion points that um
evolve around bitcoin haven't changed
for that long it's been many years we've
been talking about stores of value
payment systems as well so these points
generally don't change but i think the
philosophy behind it sometimes get lost
and in the early days there was a lot of
that you know this was a
non-nation-state currency this was
something which uh was decentralized and
anyone could partake in and blah blah
blah so
i think that message kind of gets lost
along the way and and i've often thought
about this like is this just a natural
thing which which is always going to
happen because you know when you when
you think about the good old days like
there wasn't that many people and now
you've got literally tens of millions of
people in this thing so you will get new
narratives evolved you will get like
people talking about different stuff and
i think like trying to force it in one
direction is probably bad so
like i would say the biggest thing that
has changes is the philosophy you know
the philosophical sort of you know why
bitcoin in the first place well you know
we don't want people that are unelected
that i don't know and they are
controlling my money somehow and they
get to go and create it for xero and i
can't do that because i don't have a
license that says bank on it um that's
bad let's try and build a better system
and uh i think if people sort of looked
at it from that perspective but you know
what some people don't care and that's
the thing is some people just want to
achieve a specific goal maybe they want
to pay for something maybe they just
want number to go up um
and it as frustrating as it can be that
people don't want to talk about these
things um i think that that's just
inevitable right like that there will be
people that will just get in it because
they want to get rich um and
bitcoin crypto it's not like that um
you're not going to get into it and then
instantly become a millionaire um so
yeah i think if people take a longer
term perspective um that that would be
much better but you know one thing i
would say is i don't see people going
back
once they're in i don't think like they
might dabble up here and there but
they're never going to never touch it
again it's always going to be something
that's going to reoccur at different
points of their life so we are moving
towards that future of everything being
crypto in some form um and that's pretty
exciting because yeah the numbers don't
lie like there's always just number of
users going up which is great
so with every with all of that in mind
where do you expect us to be um
let's say like five years from now
because you know we've had the
ico boom
we've had
d5 we've had nfts we have the metaverse
now
um
where do you what do you expect to be
blowing up next
oh that's that is a good question um i
think predicting like five minutes into
the future is hard enough let alone five
years but i would say that there will be
some sort of um friction between the
state and crypto at some stage and i
would not be surprised if it comes in
the next five years um and that would be
what type of what sorry what type of
friction because what would you what
would you call now like now is friction
no you're saying random people putting
them in jail and saying anyone who
transacts in it is going to jail and
you're not allowed to do it and you must
use the euro and you must use the pound
and you must use the dollar like
ultimately
think crypto's not big enough to to get
to that point yet but when it becomes a
large percentage of gdp it will um so i
think that eventuality and some people
will say
um like certainly the institutional
investors like the sailors of the world
they'll go well institutions dampen this
and because they have billions at stake
they're much less likely for uh to allow
the state to go after them and that sort
of thing yeah maybe but i think
ultimately the state is going to have to
to change fundamentally how it functions
um if it is to adopt a new sort of money
um there is no way about it yes maybe
they some people can try and convince
them otherwise but
it's going to come to a point where
they're going to have to make a choice
um either use a sound money or don't and
and some states will go down the path of
you know banging people on the head
unfortunately but hey enough doom and
gloom um i think uh d5 will continue to
grow though uh in the next in the next
few years nfts gaming um yeah you know
we've seen gaming
like people paying for new guns and
skins and whatever in video games for
like a long time
replacing that with an nft probably
makes more sense the money that people
spend in these games they can at least
sell it and get some money back i don't
think many gamers realize that they can
literally like make a ton of money in
this thing um so
maybe that will be an eventuality this
year perhaps
yeah i mean so i'm just reading the
comments now somebody's written
something which i was just thinking um
i'll put it on screen
i disagree there are too many huge
players involved already to make things
illegal at that level i don't know i do
just that's the kind of stance that i
take because let's look at michael
sayler michael stratton for example they
bought i think it's 25 million yesterday
um dollars so that's around 660 bitcoin
i think it was what would they do
like what what would they what how would
they where they would they be forced to
to sell and liquidate their bitcoin
maybe uh i mean some countries actually
turkey you know recently with the the
currency sort of exchange rate problems
um people were forced to
uh exchange their dollars that they had
in bank accounts into lira if they were
doing certain transactions like real
estate transactions so that might be a
case where it might be like hey you
can't denominate your books in bitcoin
you have to forcibly go and buy our
shitcoin usd and and do that that might
be one thing i get the point of look
there's a lot of big players and
therefore it's harder for them to make
rules but this is not going to be the
case in 200 different countries around
the world and a lot of different people
have a lot of things to to gain or lose
from it so i think you will see sort of
the balkanization of a lot of different
countries some will embrace it they'll
love it it's great they'll reap the
rewards some which have a lot to lose
probably won't and yes you know having
big people involved it might help but
ultimately like if everyone in the
country starts transacting in something
which is not the national currency then
that like there is no way for the state
to operate like you're going to pay
policemen and and firemen and whatever
else and something which is you know
venezuela style devaluing like they're
literally not going to turn up to work
um so you know that might be one
scenario right and that's people have
been speaking about that kind of thing
for years um i i hope that uh you know a
lot of the institutional buyers can like
dampen any clamp downs i i am very
hopeful for that but there is always the
chance of something else happening
do you know what so i i oh my god i i'd
say that i'm an optimistic person
um but i don't know that i am do you
know that like
given what we've seen over the last two
years right
it's just fascinating the way that you
have medicine passports for certain
states in the land of the free um just
blows my mind the fact that we even got
there um like the ret i know england's
pretty much back to normal now which is
just unbelievable um
in a good way um but the rhetoric that
we had in england um
at the end of 2021 when they were trying
to decide how to move forward whether to
go into lockdown whether to bring in
medicine passports or whatever it is um
people were talking about um uninjected
people i'm choosing my words wisely um
for algorithm purposes um people would
say that um uninjected people they
called them refusenix um and like all
these you know really vilifying them um
and so like nothing would
surprise me um i do hope that the amount
of institutional backing that it has
particularly from the likes of um
microstrategy elon musk and
jack not that jack can do much at this
point because he's not part of twitter
anymore um but i do hope that that would
dampen it um but i am yet to see i think
that
states will have to adopt
this new technology but there will be a
fight cbdc's are coming
so that's what i was going to say like
right like you know china social credit
scores these sorts of things australia
was talking about them recently like
yeah of course australia
um so i think those sort of things might
be trialled in some places and and
they're going to want people to use
their coin their cbdc coin which is just
going to be like the bank database thing
and it's the same fear literally nothing
changes people often have this idea i
remember talking literally the imf uh uh
invited me like 2015 to give a talk to
central bankers in hong kong about
crypto and i was saying and about stable
coins i think it was stable coins might
have 2016 something like that but you
know coins which are pegged to the
national currency and um yeah a lot of
them were laughing it off they were
saying oh that'll never happen that's
that's dumb um you know good good one
you know tech guy you know go sit in the
corner and that's fine but um hey look
where we are now a lot of nation states
are implementing it so yeah people will
do that now they'll want people to use
their coin you know they'll want
everyone to use china coin and if you
don't you won't be able to catch the bus
um that's already the case china's
credit score um so you know living in
hong kong and certainly through all of
the protests of 2019 we saw a lot of
what can happen with when the state
doesn't like you know what you're doing
so um yeah you know i think it will
eventually
some some places will go like that um
but then hopefully there's the el
salvadors of the world which will
embrace something easier and better
yeah i think that my optimism really is
if you've been able to survive the last
two years you'll be all right right like
if you've been able to travel still
you know live your life and you've not
lost too much sleep i've lost so much
sleep over the last two years
you know if you haven't lost too much
sleep and i think you'll be able to
survive whatever comes because like the
tug of war is coming for sure i just
don't think it will win
yeah yeah and there will be like a
multipolar world as well you know there
will be competing interests some
countries will adopt some won't you know
people will people and money and capital
will flow to the countries that do um so
yeah i think you will see like oasis
that might emerge of some places in the
world which is great
george it's been so interesting chatting
with you um i can't believe that um
you're such a bitcoin og um mining
bitcoin from your computer in 2010 that
is just nuts um
where can people where can people find
you and follow you
probably the best place is uh is on
twitter um george underscore harrop so
uh so check it out there also step step
finance um yeah i'm usually available on
social just type me in you'll see a
bunch of stuff
yeah guys definitely go follow george um
if you're just tuning in now towards the
end of the show he's been a bitcoin
since 2010 that's 11 years it's pretty
insane
bitcoin og traveling the world fleeing
tyranny from um fleeing tyranny he's
originally australian so yeah
running away from that
there's a lot of tyranny there um george
thanks so much for coming on us we so
good chatting with you thank you so much
for having me it's been a pleasure and
guys thank you for watching don't forget
to tune in next week for another
brilliant guest until next time we'll
see you then
[Applause]
[Music]